Chicago high school students may soon
need to create a plan for their future
in order to graduate Mayor Rahm Emanuel
announced a new proposal this morning it
would require students to develop a post
high school plan in order to receive a
diploma if the Board of Education backs
the proposal Chicago would be the first
city to adopt such a requirement Mary
Manuel is with us now from Chicago good
morning good morning what do you think
you can achieve by this well Charlie we
live in a period of time will you earn
what you learn and the school system of
a K through 12 is not applicable to the
economy in the world that our high
school students are graduating to so
we're moving to a pre-k to college model
the first thing we did was a couple
years ago if you get a B average in high
school community college is free we want
to make 14th grade universal now so to
graduate starting with the freshman
class you have to have been a letter of
acceptance from a college a letter of
acceptance from a community college a
letter of acceptance either from the
armed services or at rate making sure
that every high school graduate we're
now getting close to an I on track for
87 percent graduation rate it was at one
time in the mid-50s every high school
graduate has a post high school
education plan because the economy
requires it and we want to make sure our
kids do not see graduation from high
school at the end point but all of them
have a plan and all of them have a
specific acceptance on how to go post
high school education that is what the
economy requires and that is what
they're gonna need to succeed in life
what's the reaction from the students
mr. Mehra do you think they're buying in
yeah well I think first of all I think
yes the short answer is yes one is when
I became mayor our graduation rate was
57% we're on track as I said for 87% and
every parent and child are very excited
about our B average
free Community College now we're also
doing that plan for the making sure that
we have armed services the trades
included and four-year institutions we
already have around 62% of our kids are
already either accepted into college or
accepted into Community College and our
goal is to make sure nobody spikes the
ball
twelfth grade we want to make 14th grade
Universal that's the new goal line
that's what all of us have to desire
look the four of us are sitting around
here talking every one of us went to
college every one of us know that that
college education opened up doors as I
do
civics classes around Chicago I always
say you get a high school degree you'll
learn what a high C you'll earn what a
high school degree will give you you
earn get two years of Community College
you'll get two years worth of earnings
you get a four-year degree you're gonna
earn that you get post a four-year
degree you go become a lawyer or doctor
and so we want our kids expectation I'll
give you a little twist on this and
elementary schools across the city of
Chicago we put college flags in
kindergarten and banners across the hall
because I want the expectation just like
I do
Amy and I do with our kids just like you
do with your children college post high
school that is what is expecting if you
change the expectations it's not hard
for kids to adapt there it's a it's a
great idea just get everybody thinking
about they've got to put down on paper
what they're gonna do when they're gonna
to graduate school even just setting
that expectation not only that you won't
be able to graduate in two years unless
you show that letter of acceptance to
any one of the four outlets that we
talked about college community college
armed services or a trade mayor let me
ask you about president Trump's budget
blueprint because it includes cuts to
federal grants for after-school and
other programs how would that affect
Chicago schools well we have first of
all don't worry about Chicago schools
worry about Chicago students I look I
was a product of after school I used to
did you know dance ballet yes yeah no
that should prove that helped me and
know I could have seen that mr. mayor
that's all I know you did it I just wish
I could have seen you in anything you
have to pay a high price to get that
ticket let me just say it this way after
schools whether it's athletics artistic
or academic provide kids II not just an
education the collaboration working with
other kids exposure to other kids of
different walks of life and a caring
adult every one of us had that it's as
important part of their education and
development as
what you learned in algebra and now the
good news is we have dramatically as a
city both expanded our after-school and
summer jobs but we've done it without
either the state of Illinois being a
partner or the federal government over
the last five years and I think it's
wrong it's wrong for the kids future and
I had always say this is this what I
would want for my own children and if
the answer is no that don't do it and
it's wrong for our kids I've seen
through our program after school matters
which Maggie Daley helped set up and now
we're up to about twenty thousand thirty
thousand kids we have done it through
our Park District Schools it is wrong to
cut off schools after activities after
school our responsibilities of children
do not end when the bell goes off we
still have a responsibility to give them
activities where they discover something
about themselves all right mr. mayor we
thank you unfortunately we're out of
time but you're onto something there's
so much of the news about Chicago has
not been so great about the shooting
it's good to see that you can tell us
something positive this morning that's
coming out of the city thank you very
much thank you very much we appreciate
your time